braced for a battering it was the south
coast that felt the full force of winds
that were a struggle to stand up in the
Port of Dover forced to close as boats
struggled to contend with giant waves
wind speeds of 97 miles per hour
registered on the Isle of Wight weather
like this is actually fairly common out
in the Atlantic and usually in this
versus before it reaches the UK however
in the case of storm Kiara this
exceptional weather that we're
experiencing is being caused by a low
pressure system that's four thousand
miles wide and stretches from Florida to
Scandinavia few parts of the UK and
Ireland escaped the storms effects seats
left empty at many of the big sporting
fixtures canceled for public safety
Royal Parks were closed for the same
reason the weather bad enough to keep
the Queen from attending her regular
Sunday church service developed as a low
over Eastern America and then it has
just whistled away eastwards across the
Atlantic driven by a really strong
Jetstream I think there's something like
265 mile an hour jet stream so it's
unusually strong and behind storm Kirra
there's much colder air as well and even
though the warnings will have sort of
abated a little bit and it won't be as
extreme or damaging perhaps it'll still
be really lively volatile airmass
there'll be lots of showers around you
can see there snow on the horizon as
well over two hundred and eighty-one
thousand homes experienced power cuts
those who ventured out were confronted
with treacherous conditions on the roads
thankfully the driver of this car wasn't
hurt in Blackpool firefighters had to
rescue this driver who became stuck in
floodwater the seven bridge was forced
to close over concerns it was too
dangerous to cross
trains in Manchester were canceled
because of flooding like this while down
south rail operators had their own set
of problems to contend with
but the perfect storm was a welcome
guest for our renewable energy providers
with the wind gusts being the biggest
provider of electricity for the UK today
across the country hundreds of domestic
and international flights were cancelled
frustrating but few would fancy flying
in this planes that did get off the
ground faced a bumpy landing but for one
be a flight records were broken
overnight for the fastest ever
supersonic New York to London crossing
in less than five hours as a passenger
plane clocked up speeds of more than 80
miles per hour on the back of the jet
stream this was noise that homeowners in
Humberside woke up to a precursor to
this with a hundred and twenty three
flood warnings in place defences were
overwhelmed it's quite fun
yeah hold on to me while the worst is
hopefully now over the aftermath of
storm Kira will take some time to clean
up
Katie Spencer Sky News